just a week ago Democrats staged what
can I guess politely be called her
rebellion and they almost killed the
proposal what's changed in a week
politely is probably the right word mark
what's changed in the week is not
necessarily mark the votes but the
strategy employed by House and Senate
Republican leaders in terms of trying to
get this bill passed originally they had
linked both the fast-track trade bill
with a separate trade bill that would
provide assistance to American workers
displaced by trade deals now they've
separated those and today the house as
you said earlier this afternoon passing
the fast-track trade bill for a second
time sending it back to the Senate the
catch here is that it's going to require
again a handful of Democrats who remain
many of whom remain opposed to the
president's fast-track trade Authority
to remain opposed to his entire trade
agenda requires them to sign up as well
and the sense we're getting from talking
to some of those Senate Democrats is
that they have real questions about
whether or not they can support it
unless they're convinced that Republican
leaders will also consider the
assistance part of this trade package
one of those lawmakers is Chris Coons a
pro trade Democrat from Delaware I spoke
with earlier what many Democrats want to
see out of this trade bill is stronger
enforcement and stronger support for
those workers who might be negatively
affected by trade without some guarantee
without some path forward for all of
those to get done it's difficult for me
to take another vote on TPA and so Chris
Coons needs to have assurances not only
that this fast track bill is going to
move forward but also mark and Scarlett
that this aid for American workers will
also be part of the package and right
now he told me he does not yet have the
assurances from Republican leaders that
that's indeed going to happen not only
they get a vote but that it's going to
pass so sounds like the president has
his work cut out for him and maybe has
some more nights of personal lobbying
ahead of him how tough a vote is this
going to be for Democrats like Coons
well it's going to be very tough you
know he told me that after his first
vote in support of the president's trade
agenda he's heard it from organized
labor some of his strongest constituents
as strongest supporters back in his home
state of Delaware very tough vote for
Democrats particularly when you've got
arguably the the front
runner in the presidential race among
Democrats not putting her support behind
this so far so very tough moment for
Senate Democrats the president's
counting on at least a handful of them
to get this over the finish line it is
not a done deal yet but we could see a
vote Scarlett as soon as next week in
the Senate that'll tell us a lot okay
Peter so it is not a done deal yet what
if it fails is there a back-up plan is
their plan see right now mark there
there isn't a back-up plan again this is
as much to do with process as it does
with substance they're trying to find
some pathway that gets both of these
trade measures to the President's desk
with his signature it's going to require
trust on the part of both Republicans
and Democrats going forward and right
now there's not a whole lot of trust out
there we'll see how this shakes out any
idea Peter what the president's prepared
to offer up to Senate Democrats well
listen he's been having close
conversations with them Chris Coons was
among the Democrats over at the White
House yesterday meeting privately with
the president trying to sort of
strategize this trying to find out how
they could soften the blow here he's
already offered Scarlett to campaign
with Democrats who vote for him but this
is a lame duck president it's not
exactly the kind of offer a lot of them
were hoping for at this particular
moment in time something that could
soften the blow would help and right now
it's not clear exactly what that would
be yeah campaign with them it's like
thanks but not necessarily no thanks
okay Peter Cook our chief Washington
correspondent joining us from Washington
thanks a lot